[Applause]
mr. president mr. Provost madam
secretary college heads Dean colleagues
friends families and most of all women
and men of the class of 2017 welcome to
this day
[Applause]
Baccalaureate is one of the major
markers of your Yale journey and it
serves as the closing bookends to the
late summer of 2013 when you gathered in
the same space for your freshman
assembly baccalaureate invites you to
pause during what is an exhausting
weekend so please take a deep breath
slowly exhale and invest yourself in
this moment I now call on the university
chaplain
my sisters and brothers I invite you to
join me in the spirit of Prayer Almighty
and loving God you are the one who gives
us this day and all our days in the
majesty of this life moment we your
beloved children of different colors
Creed's generations stories and tongues
are gathered in this place as one human
family United in jubilant celebration we
are filled with gratitude for our
families friends teachers and guides
their arms have sheltered us their
shoulders have boosted us and today
their hearts store for us
eternal God it is you who calls us to
our full humanity as we celebrate our
accomplishment we are humbled and
overwhelmed by what lies ahead
let us continue to caress the beauty of
your creation and may our souls know
true delight as we awaken to the Wonder
and the mystery of our own unfolding
lives through unity of mind and spirit
hold us ever close as we seek to live in
your world wisely in the steadfast
pursuit of your life and your truth for
this we say Amen
all that which pervades earth sky and
heaven which is worthy of worship that
has no beginning that which is the light
of wisdom and truth let us meditate on
the radiance of that divinity made that
brilliance help inspire and illuminate
our mind that one which represents water
light and is the quintessence in all
things made that almighty spirit
pervading the earth atmosphere and
heaven bless us with enlightenment
send forth your light and your truth
they will lead me they will bring me to
your holy mountain to your dwelling
place that I may come to the altar of
God God my delight my joy that I may
praise you with the heart O God my God
you are the light of the world a city
built on a hill cannot be hid no one
after lighting a lamp puts it under the
bushel basket but on the lamp bed and it
gives light to all in the house in the
same way let your light shine before
others so that they may see your good
works and give glory to your God in
heaven God is the light of the heavens
and earth the likeness of his light is
that of Anish in which there is a lamp
the lamp is in a glass the glass is as
it were a brilliant star lit from a
blessed tree an olive trees neither of
the East nor of the West whose oil seems
to glow even no fire has touched it life
upon life God guides whom He wills to
his life God makes parables for Humanity
and God has knowledge of everything
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you
[Applause]
[Music]
on this occasion it is customary for the
president to deliver a baccalaureate
address and for the Dean of the old
college to offer a few readings four
years ago you came here as strangers but
now you leave here as friends think
about that think about how much you have
changed since you arrived think about
all the differences that define those
initial moments when you met your
suitemates
and thought maybe with some inward alarm
how is this going to work for an entire
year is he really going to wake up at
5:00 a.m. every day is she really going
to leave her laundry on the floor all
semester wow I never knew had such
strong feelings about country rock
classical electronica jazz trip-hop emo
when you think of back on those fragile
first days it is a miracle that a
community was born out of so much
difference it's impossible to know
precisely what makes that happen even in
hindsight but every year a new group of
implausibly different people from every
corner of the globe begins to turn into
friends for life
you will soon be leaving here with your
degrees but what you will take with you
into the world every day is the
community and the sense of community
that you have formed here I ask you to
join me for the next few minutes
thinking about that what makes a
community is a community made by its
memories for a thoughtful engagement
with these questions I turn to Elijah
Cooper the 1993 graduate of Yale College
who was in my disgust discussion section
when I was a graduate student and who
since then has written with grace about
a particular community his own family in
his book falling Cooper writes about his
two young daughters and how he wrestles
with the stresses and tensions and
transcendence --is that are part of
belonging to a family but the metaphor
easily extends to something as large and
complicated as a yale community he
writes daily rhythms create memories
walks to school breakfasts around the
kitchen table this is why I take my
daughters to cafes after school and we
drink hot chocolate and sit in the same
seats and look out the same window our
days accumulate painful memories like
seventh grade are unavoidable but maybe
our good memories can sit next to our
painful memories and watch over them
cushion them and soften their jagged
edges good memories hold us we create
them every day by walking out the door
or looking across the field
surely time and forgetfulness help too
but I'd like to think we are protected
by the memory of chocolate sometimes I
think we are memories I mean humans are
memories
we are the stories we tell and the
experiences we share in what must be the
greatest miracle of chemistry we are
able to enter into the memories of those
we love
we burrow into them drop down into their
cells in this way I hope I can nestle
into my children into the smallest part
of them and will always be with them
what makes a community
is a community made by its values you
came here expecting rightly to do to go
on to do great things for me it does not
matter what you do but how you do it go
to the daycare center the executive
suite the laboratory the equities market
the judicial chambers the Savannah
wherever you do the labor of the world
after you graduate invest yourself in it
but also commit yourselves to open
inquiry and understand that our fates
are linked in his new book on tyranny 20
lessons from the 20th century my
colleague and eminent historian Timothy
Snyder speaks to the importance of this
commitment the use of the lessons of the
past to remind us that our present and
future rests on a gossamer structure of
social interaction in which we are all
active participants I draw here from
three lessons first defend institutions
it is institutions that help us to
preserve decency they need our help as
well do not speak of our institutions
unless you make them yours by acting on
their behalf institutions do not protect
themselves they fall one after the other
unless each is defended from the
beginning so choose an institution you
care about a court a newspaper a law a
labor union and take its side second
believe in truth to abandon facts is to
abandon freedom if nothing is true then
no one can criticize power because there
is no basis upon which to do so if
nothing is true then all is spectacle
third make eye contact and small talk
this is not just polite it is part of
being a citizen and a responsible member
of society it is also a way to stay in
touch with your surroundings break down
social barriers and understand whom you
should and should not trust if we enter
a culture of denunciation you will want
to know the psychological landscape of
your daily life what makes a community
is a community made up of the
unacknowledged through her poetry
Lucille Clifton asks us to broaden our
understanding of who can be an expert of
who can be a vital contributing member
of our society of who in fact helps
define a community as I read her poem
think about the dining hall workers the
custodians the grounds crew and the
administrative assistants you have seen
or even better come to know during your
Yale career think about how they have
made your life easier more complete and
more meaningful recognize their
expertise and labor remember how they
used their skills to support you thank
them study the masters like my aunt
Timmy it was her iron ore one like hers
that smooths the sheets the master poet
slept on home or hotel what matters is
he lay himself down on her handiwork and
dreamed she dreamed two words some
Cherokee some Maasai and some huge and
particular as hope if you had heard her
chanting a she ironed you would
understand form and line and discipline
and order and America
what makes a community it is made up of
memories values and the unacknowledged
it is also made up of you when I look at
you I see many things love contestation
ideology zaniness pride brilliance
insecurity creativity psets essay
deadlines wenzels more p-sets
loathes chicken tenders and kate shark
as you leave you'll have to explain it
to your parents as you leave this place
as you leave this place remember these
things remember what you have given to
this community and it to you remember
the transcendent as well as the
chocolate remember to articulate and
defend your values remember to
acknowledge the work and skill and care
of those who labor invisibly on your
behalf
remember to understand your role in
helping this and future communities
realize their potential most of all
remember the story of your community
wherever you make it and then tell
others what you see it is only through
the telling of these stories that we can
ever help our communities become the
light that is in the truth I leave you
with an excerpt from Frank O'Hara's
having a coke with you I look at you and
I would rather look at you that all the
portraits in the world except possibly
for the polish writer occasionally and
anyway it's in the Frick which thank
heavens you haven't gone to yet so we
can go together for the first time and
the fact that you move so beautifully
more or less take care of futurism just
as at home I never think of the nude
descending a staircase or at a rehearsal
a single drawing of Leonardo
Michelangelo that used to WoW me and
what good does all the research of the
Impressionists do them when they never
got the right person to stand near the
tree when the Sun sank or for that
matter Marino Marini when he didn't pick
the rider as carefully as the horse it
seems they were all cheated of some
marvelous experience which is not going
to go wasted on me which is why I'm
telling you about it
women and men of the class of 2017 it
has been an honor and a privilege to be
a service to your community take care of
it take care of each other and take care
of yourselves thank you and
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
before I begin class of 2017 guests
families members might do join me in
thanking Dean Holloway for his service
to Yale and wishing him luck as the next
Provost of Northwestern University
graduates of the class of 2017 family
members friends it's so good to be with
here with you today
a day filled with joy and hope and I'm
sure a bit of pride as well
there's a wonderful Yale tradition that
I'd like to honor right now may I ask
all of the families and friends here
today to rise and recognize the
outstanding and graduating members of
the class of 2017
and now class of 2017 may I ask you to
consider all those who have supported
your arrival at this milestone and to
please rise and recognize them
[Applause]
so last month I flew to California to
celebrate Passover with my family as
many of you know this is the holiday
that memorializes the experiences of
Jews as slaves in Egypt and then
celebrates their deliverance from
bondage through reading a liturgical
texts called the Hagaddah
and eating ritual foods everyone at the
Passover Seder is invited to reflect on
this history as if they had experienced
it themselves the Passover themes of
slavery and freedom resonate as clearly
today as they did millennia ago
many contemporary haga don't reference
modern struggles such as African
Americans fight for emancipation and
civil rights and present-day efforts to
end human trafficking my family uses the
traditional Haggadah sponsored by
Maxwell House coffee since 1932
apparently it was also used by former
President Obama at the White House's
annual seder my favorite passage comes
early in the evening we are reminded
that because we were strangers in the
land of Egypt we therefore must welcome
strangers to our own Seder we recite let
all those who are hungry enter and eat
all who are in distress come and
celebrate Passover with us these
sentiments go a long way back they're
written in Aramaic the everyday spoken
language of must of the Middle East from
2,000 to 3,000 years ago so that they
could be easily understood by those who
might have responded to the offer in the
past the head of the household
open the door open the door to the home
and read these words inviting all who
past to come and join in the celebration
remembering what it was like to be a
stranger is not only important at
Passover
we're told repeatedly in the Jewish
scripture to show kindness toward
strangers the Torah warns against
harming a stranger anywhere from thirty
five to forty six distinct times
depending on how you translate it in
Exodus we are told you shall not wronged
a stranger or oppress him for you were
strangers in the land of Egypt elsewhere
in Exodus this is written for you were
strangers in a strange land that's the
inspiration for the title of the popular
science fiction novel by Robert Heinlein
and again in leviticus we read when a
stranger resides with you in your land
you shall not do him wrong the stranger
who resides with you shall be to you as
the native among you and you shall love
him as yourself for you were aliens in
the land of Egypt Judea knows Judaism is
not alone in this concern for the
stranger in the parable of the Last
Judgement Jesus says I was a foreigner
and you welcomed me in his
interpretation of this passage the
bishop emeritus of the Archdiocese of
Hartford
Peter Rosa says that welcoming the
foreigner
welcoming the foreigner is equivalent to
welcoming Jesus later in the Epistle to
the Hebrews we were advised do not
neglect to show hospitality to strangers
for by this some have entertained angels
without knowing it imagine if all
strangers all foreigners were treated as
if they were divine messengers
the Koran instructs Muslims similarly
and do good unto your parents and near
of kin and unto orphans and the needy
and the neighbor from among your own
people and the neighbor who is a
stranger and the friend by your side and
the wayfarer there's an ancient Hindu
scripture that says the guest is
equivalent to God hospitality to guests
and strangers called manushya yagna is
one of the five great sacrifices to be
carried out daily according to Vedic
practice turning back to the Old
Testament we find this reminder worded a
bit differently from the others
you shall not oppress a stranger as you
yourself know the feelings of a stranger
for you were strangers in the land of
Egypt this is also translated quite
beautifully as for you know the heart of
a stranger okay psychologists and I'm a
psychologist called this kind of
understanding knowing the heart of
another empathy and I've linked it to
acting ethically and morally we're more
likely to treat other people well if we
can find ways to empathize with them
here we are told how to act how not to
mistreat strangers because we can
understand their feelings their hearts
but is it easy to show empathy not
always this is one reason why no group
no religion has ever completely lived up
to its own ideals regarding the
treatment of outsiders intolerance and
oppression have been a ubiquitous
feature of many human societies when we
are feeling lost threat or fear it is
hard for us to put ourselves in someone
else's shoes
in fact stressful and uncertain times
may lead us to point fingers at others
to search for convenient scapegoats
rather than empathize with them today it
is not only the immigrants and refugees
among us who are strangers in a strange
land across the United States and even
across the world we have all become
strangers to each other
we find it difficult to understand and
engage perspectives with which we
disagree we can't imagine how people in
our own country can feel and act as they
do and despite being in constant
communication we feel increasingly
disconnected from one another in the
last thirty years according to a recent
article in Forbes the number of
Americans who report that they have no
friends zero has tripled how can this be
how can this be when we can friend
hundreds of individuals on social media
with the tap of a finger yet the more
one's life is oriented around the
Internet the lonelier one tends to be
it's easier to email text and tweet than
to put away our smartphones and make a
new friend with a living breathing human
this is not a new phenomenon and the
Internet may actually attract more than
its fair share of blame at the turn of
the 20th century the French sociologist
Emile Durkheim
wrote about the emergence of anomie a
sense of being unmoored or unconnected
to social norms and institutions
he thought that great changes in his
lifetime
the rise of industry mass production the
growth of cities were responsible for
these feelings of disconnect essentially
later but a few years before concerns
about the internet and social media
started to shape this conversation
political scientist Robert Putnam used
the vivid metaphor of Bowling Alone to
describe the general breakdown of true
personal social networks in contemporary
society Putnam found that we are no
longer a community of joiners we no
longer define ourselves by clubs and
civic organizations that represent our
hobbies and our interests so what
happens when social ties weaken how do
we feel secure when we are no longer
embedded deeply in social networks or
community groups one possible outcome is
that we retreat into ourselves we may
spend a lot of time staring into the
mirror attending only to information
that is consistent with our pre-existing
beliefs we focus on our own doubts our
own vulnerabilities our own
preoccupations we've become isolated we
become lonely we have all known the long
loneliness wrote Dorothy day and we have
learned that the only solution is love
and that love comes with community as
our Dean just told us without community
without empathy we cannot see ourselves
in the eyes of the strangers among us
instead those strangers are the best
ignored and at worst demonized and
despite the teachings of Hinduism Islam
Christianity Judaism and many other
traditions to the contrary we no longer
welcome the strangers to our table
rather we build walls to keep them away
from us perhaps on a beautiful sunny
afternoon in the last four years you
took a walk over to the Grove Street
cemetery and you found the tombstone of
Kingman Brewster yells 17th president
Brewster let's University during a
tumultuous period in its history and in
the nation's history he oversaw Co
education and tried to keep the peace
while the black pants
trials were held in New Haven Brewster's
epitaph reads the presumption of
innocence is not only a legal concept in
common law and in common sense it
requires a generosity of spirit a
generosity of spirit toward the stranger
the expectation of what is best rather
than what is worst in each other
Brewster was familiar with conflict
he knew how deeply people could disagree
with one another how fear and
misunderstanding could divide them yet
he expected the best in others that was
his common sense
let it be ours too empathy is a powerful
tool Tana has eight coats the writer and
social critic has called for a muscular
empathy rooted in curiosity such a
muscular empathy should inspire us and
spur us to action to serve others and
our communities members of the class of
2017 you've just spent four years on a
campus that strives to be welcoming and
inclusive you've made lasting
friendships with people from a variety
of backgrounds and walks of life
although you are strangers to each other
when you met together you helped build a
strong community here at Yale you have
all stood up and saying the seasons come
the seasons go the earth is green or
white with snow but time and change
shall not avail to break the friendships
formed at Yale
I
I urge you I urge you to take these
experiences out into the world a world
that desperately needs your service your
curiosity and yes your empathy I hope
you identify with the plight of the
other walking a mile in the shoes of a
stranger by welcoming guests by doing
good to strangers by knowing the hearts
of others you may well entertain angels
members of the class of 2017 please rise
as you go on to a world that is all
before you hand-in-hand with wandering
steps and slow bring to that world all
that your Yale education has given you
the ability to appreciate complexity
even while seeking simplicity to engage
critically even while listening
respectfully to recognize your
responsibilities while finding pleasures
in your new communities and to welcome
into these communities the strangers
among us we are delighted to salute your
accomplishments and we are proud of your
achievements
remember to give thanks for all that has
brought you to this day and go forth
from this place with grateful hearts
paying back the gifts you have received
here by using your minds your voices and
your hands to strengthen your new
communities and your world
congratulations class of 2017
[Applause]
[Music]
you
Oh
ah
[Music]
you
may God bless you and keep you may the
eternal one show you favor and be
gracious to you may the Holy One cause
light to shine upon you and grant you
peace and let us say Amen
[Music]
you
[Music]